we are told to use estimation to tell
whether each estimated quotient is
reasonable or unreasonable so we have a
bunch of estimated quotients here so
someone is estimating that 2419 divided
by three is roughly equal to 7,500 we
have to figure out is that reasonable or
unreasonable and then we have two more
quotients to figure out if it's
unreasonable or reasonable so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
on your own before we work through it
together
all right now let's work through it
together and the way that I'd like to
tackle this is just try to do the
estimation myself so I'll start with
this first one
so 2419 divided by three well one way to
estimate is try to think about what
numbers are these close to that are a
little bit easier to compute with you
some people would say they're a little
bit friendlier so to speak well three is
already a pretty simple number a pretty
friendly number 2419 well it's a little
bit more complicated but I could try to
think of is there a multiple of three
that's close to 2419 that is a fairly
friendly number well I do know that 3
times 8 is 24 so if I had something like
2,400 which is the same thing as 2,400
that'd be easy to divide by 3 so I could
say that this is roughly equal to 2,400
divided by 3 all I did is I said hey
2419 for estimation purposes let's just
say it's roughly equal to 2400 and then
2400 is fairly straightforward and
divided by 3 this over here 24 divided
by 3 is 8 so 2400 divided by 3 is 800 so
this is going to be 800 so 2400 19
divided by 3 should be roughly around
800 now they're saying that it's roughly
7,500 that's a lot more than 800 if they
said 750 then I'd say hey that's pretty
reasonable but they're saying 7,500
that's all
most ten times more than 800 so this I
would say is unreasonable all right now
let's think about this next one and
again pause the video and see if you can
have a go at it alright so I'm just
going to try to estimate again so four
hundred and thirty-five divided by five
let's say that's roughly equal to so an
easy multiple of five that's close to
435 if I want to think of a friendly
number it might be 400 so I'll say
that's roughly equal to 400 divided by
five and now we know that 40 divided by
five is 10 is 8 sorry and so for 40 tens
divided by five is eight tens so this is
going to be equal to 80 and you could
think about it the other way five times
eight tens is going to be 40 tens which
is the same thing as 400 so this thing
should be roughly equal to 80 well
that's exactly what we estimated so that
feels very reasonable all right this
last one so pause the video and see if
you can have a go with that all right so
we have six thousand two hundred and two
and there say divided by two
now we could say that's approximately
equal to a roughly equal to well if I
just want to do it very roughly I could
say hey six thousand two hundred and two
let's just go to six thousand just to
make things really easy divided by two
and so this is going to be six thousands
divided by 2 would be three thousands or
3,000 but here they have three hundred
that's one tenth of what I have over
here so this is unreasonable and we're
done